on this earth day our correspondents are
fanning out around the globe to bring us
stories about our planet's health our
earth matters coverage begins with how
deforestation threatens the Amazon
rainforest vladimir duthiers just spent
three days deep in the world's largest
jungle which we have scientists trying
to understand the effects of cutting
down so many trees he joins us from a
forest just outside Brazil's capital
city Brasilia flat good morning good
morning for the past 20 years
environmentalist here in Brazil thought
they were making progress as the rate of
Amazon deforestation slowed way down but
now activists are noticing it's starting
to speed up again combine that with a
newly elected Brazilian president who's
openly critical of environmental
priorities and the scientists we spent a
week in the jungle with say they're
seriously concerned a trip to the Amazon
is no simple journey nor one lightly
taken and it usually involves multiple
flights on planes that get noticeably
smaller as the region's get more remote
after another hour in the back of a
truck we're finally here 10 guru ranch
this 200 thousand acre industrial farm
may not be what you imagine is the
Amazon but it sits right up against
these massive walls of dense rainforest
in essence it's the last line of
civilization and the front line in the
battle against deforestation for us is a
perfect laboratory to work it's a very
large farm it's half for us and half the
farmland so we're able to set up
different experiments in both farmland
and forests to see that the differences
are Mike Coe is a soldier in that battle
as the head of the Woods Hole Research
Centre science station based here at the
ranch is weapons our data if you cut
down the forth you're just adding to
global warming you're doing it by
increasing the amount of carbon goes
right and you're doing it by just
heating up the surface since the rise of
large-scale industrial farming here in
the past 50 years scientists like Coe
estimate that almost 20% of the original
Amazon has been deforested cut down to
make way for agriculture
to measure the impact of all those lost
trees you've got to get above it all
this tower allows us to measure how
porous our breathing in and out and
that's where scientists Paulo Brando
works first thing you notice when you're
130 feet above the Amazon is how
breathtaking the view is from up here
but for scientists it is not about the
view it's about the science that trees
probably three or four tons of carbon
that is storing so they assimilated
carbon that authorized would be in the
atmosphere
what happens if these trees are cut down
and that carbon is released into the
atmosphere
this carbon goes into the atmosphere and
contribute to heat trapping in that
material there's as much carbon captured
and stored in all the trees of the
Amazon as the amount the entire planet
has emitted over the past ten years cut
them down and we effectively double the
heat trapping gases of the past decade
but the trees are more than just carbon
containers in some regions of the Amazon
about 30 percent of the rain depends on
the trees in some parts of the Amazon it
rains because of the trees yes because
of the trees they're a key part of the
global weather cycle they soak up water
from the soil it evaporates off the tree
tops and creates the life-giving rain
that supports millions of people
downwind I prefer to call the air
conditioner of the earth because all
that water rains out somewhere else so
without that recycling of water you've
got a lot less rain you've got a lot
hotter planet
KO's data shows that with less trees the
dry season around here has expanded by
three and a half weeks in the past 50
years the problem is it's not being
reported each year there's more being
taken out and there's none being
replaced so that's actually the problem
Coe and his team may have discovered a
solution by relying on the jungles
original inhabitants using field data
and these remote cameras the Woods Hole
team has learned that large mammals
actually are the best fertilizers they
are great at eating feed and then
dropping them somewhere else tracking
those seeds because those seeds when
they hit the ground lead to
reforestation right zamel czar playing a
big role in
getting new trees to grow also playing a
big role indigenous human populations
who live in the area with generations of
climate knowledge over a huge swath of
territory they're the people most
immediately affected by recent droughts
and previously unheard of forest fires
his grandfather recognized that there
were changes happening the Akuma
souvaine
things are changing here and there the
pressure is squeezing them squeezing
them and they might also have some of
the answers can be really important to
engage indigenous people in this whole
discussion of how can we make a
landscape that works for everyone those
Native communities have long been
protected by the Brazilian government
but that too is threatening to change
Brazil's new president jarba Cynara
recently shifted power over from the
government's indigenous rights agency to
the agricultural ministry and some see
that as just another attempt to exploit
the rainforests that these people have
relied on for their existence for
generations John Wow Vlad what a great
story and what a great adventure for you
what was it like but hey just to
experience the welcoming of the
indigenous community it was absolutely
fabulous and to hear the Chiefs son who
we spoke to tell us that his grandfather
recognized these changes it was
incredibly moving and there's a custom
that happens when you do visit their
village they bring you to their crafts
selection and we pick something out for
Gail because it's yellow it's bold and
it's an honor of you being named the
time 100 one of the time 100 people so
we told them that there were three
Chiefs back in New York and this is from
one of those Chiefs and yeah yellow is
certainly my colour loose and I wore
this earth dress today to go with it to
go with Earth Day it looked better on
the hanger I have to say I could have
used that necklace today thank you very
much
well meeting why did you tell them how
much Gail loves necklaces they are we
told them that we told them how much
Gail has necklaces and that she loves
yellow yes I this is what they picked
for us excellent choice bladder
let's save the trees thank you so much
thank you I really appreciate thank you
so much glad